am morgen die damen
ja danke ich habe wunderbar geschlafen
und bin fit für den tag
welche laus über die leber gelaufen
philipp könntest du uns bitte
alleinlassen laster und ich müssen was
bereden
ich nehme an es geht nicht darum wenn
nächste woche das klo putzt oder doch so
ernst
na dann viel spaß
lotte ich wollte nicht dass du denkst
basteln
jetzt sag mir nicht du hast das nicht
mit absicht gemacht was soll ich denn
mit absicht gemacht haben
du hast mir mein freund ausgespannt ich
wusste doch gar nicht dass jonas sein
freund ist so heißt er und du kannst es
nicht gewusst haben er war doch jeder wg
da war ich aber nicht hier wären uns
verpasst
das habt ihr doch abgesprochen
gibt es doch zu das nein ich hätte
niemals was mit deinem freund angefangen
wenn ich das gewusst hätte
du musst mir das glauben lotta zieht
nicht alles oft schon musste mir glauben
er hat wohl des volkes damit bekommen
dass wir zwei freundinnen sind als ich
in die adresse gegeben habe
kommen
dies alles in ordnung mit den menschen
wir helfen
einmal ist sie vielleicht nicht so aus
ein verdammt guter zuhörer
wenn du willst
to live nation mädchen mädchen oder
zeigt sich wieder 1 ehrlichkeit ist das
a und o zahlen bitte moment mal
man muss prioritäten setzen
hier
nicht nur deine freundin sollte sich
inter dank